in June the fill a spacelander woke up
after a seven-month nap and started
sending messages back to earth from a
comp if you lay a washing machine sized
robot was made by the european space
agency and its mission has been years in
the making Thile was launched into space
inside the Rosetta spacecraft back on
March second 2004 the beginning of a 10
year 4 billion mile trip through the
solar system Rosetta performed a series
of looping orbits around the Sun using
gravity from Earth and Mars to slowly
guide it past and then into orbit around
comet 67 the Rosetta sent thousands of
stunning photographs showing flaring
gases and dust bouncing off the oddly
shaped comment that's about as long as
New York City's Central Park three
months after Rosetta arrived at comet 67
on November twelfth 2014 the feely
Lander separated and descended down to
the surface but the landing did not go
entirely as planned after a series of
bounces the feel I came to rest in a
shaded cross the fillet is covered in
large solar panels the powered systems
but due to the reduced sunlight in the
crevice the lander went into hibernation
after just 57 hours but before going to
sleep feel like beamed information about
the Comets surface up to the orbiting
Rosetta which then sent the information
back to earth for seven months
scientists have been waiting and
wondering if feel I would ever speak
again
but then on jun 13 2015 feel i phoned
home it awoke from hibernation when the
comet rotated back towards the sun and
recharged the spacecraft's battery for
85 seconds fillet spoke to its team on
earth scientists recently revealed
fillet has detected 16 organic compounds
on the surface of the comet as well as
water vapor carbon monoxide and carbon
dioxide importantly some of these
compounds are the building blocks of
life and their presence could hold clues
to the origins of the solar system